hello and welcome to Sophie Ridge on
Sunday as a new prime minister a new
cabinet and new priorities and number
one on that list is planning for a nodal
brexit Boris Johnson has set up a wall
cabinet to take the UK out of the EU by
the end of October by any means
necessary like it or not the brexit
temperature has been cranked up a few
notches so we've got a blockbuster show
today first we'll be hearing from the
Labour Party leader Jeremy Corbyn not
content with just one Party leader will
also be speaking to the new Lib Dem
leader Joseph Winston and one of the
cabinet's new faces Russia soon act will
also be here in the studio and with no
deal preparations ramping up will get
the view from Europe with the French MEP
and the former Europe Minister Natalie
wazoo but first this week I travelled to
Mansfield one of the keen marginal
constituencies that could decide the
next election and I sat down with the
Labour leader Jeremy Corbyn I started by
asking about that election which might
not be too far away so you're now on
your third conservative Prime Minister
Boris Johnson seems to be gearing up for
an election are you absolutely I've got
my summer campaign plan in place we've
got most of our candidates selected in
all our marginal constituencies we have
many of our policy announcements in
place particularly the ones on the green
industrial revolution and the green new
deal that we're putting forward and
working out more details on our health
and social care policies but
fundamentally it's about reducing
inequality in Britain and about
investing in good quality sustainable
jobs for the future through the green
energy revolution a bit worried about
going up against Boris Johnson in an
election I mean he's won in labour
territory before in London not in the
slightest
we'll go out there and we'll make our
case I don't get involved in personal
abuse I don't make any personal abuse I
don't do personal as far as I'm
concerned the issues are too serious we
do in a country that is more unequal
than almost any other in Europe that is
becoming more unequal than in many parts
of the country there's been no real
investment since the end of the miners
strike where we are today in Mansfield
as an example of that
we have to have a change of approach and
it has to be about investment it has to
be about real opportunities for young
people so they don't go into university
and come out with debt they do get the
choice real choice of an apprenticeship
or a university education we are in
month old as you say and somewhere that
was labor for 94 years before the
Conservatives took it at the last
election how are you gonna win six like
this back our candidate here Sonia wood
working really hard all of our party
members working really hard taking that
message out there we don't have to be a
nation of food banks I met somebody an
hour ago who was organizing a hunger
holiday campaign in order to collect
food to ensure that children who would
normally get free school meals managed
to get a lunch all through the school
holidays modern Britain 21st century
fifth richest country in the world that
is simply wrong it's these inequalities
that have to be dealt with so it's
pretty clear that you want an election
so what are you going to make it happen
when you're going to call a
no-confidence vote in the Prime Minister
Parliament goes back in September and I
think it's at that point we'll look at
the situation there but it's also up to
the Prime Minister what he decides to do
as well because if he's trying to take
us out on a No Deal brexit at the end of
October we will oppose that so can you
guarantee that you'll call a confidence
motion before we leave the table I can
guarantee you this we will do everything
to prevent a No Deal exit and we'll do
everything to challenge this government
and we'll do it at a time by choosing
okay so what do you think the election
is going to be well an election takes
about seven weeks from the point at
which Parliament votes to hold it under
the fixed term Parliament act in
two-thirds of all MPs have to vote for
it but if the government puts sat down
such a motion we would support it
because we think the public do deserve
an election we have a government that
doesn't really have a majority that has
a deal made with the DUP some years ago
and cannot win votes in Parliament
Theresa May was defeated more times than
any other Prime Minister by the biggest
majorities ever
and Johnson has put together a cabinet
of ideologically extremely right-wing
people and the leader of the house
instead of getting on with reforming
Parliament seems more concerned about
apostrophes at the end of letters now
let's talk about brexit shall we because
when that election comes brexit will be
of utmost importance to many people
including people here in Mansfield which
voted 70 percent to leave the EU they're
going to want to know what your policy
is on brexit so what is it are you now
supporting a second referendum at all
circumstances what we're saying is no
deal wit oppose and we think people
should have a final choice on it and
they could have vote them between remain
or whatever option Boris Johnson decides
to put them at that time what I'd also
say to Mansfield and to everywhere else
is you've not had the investment you
should have had British governments have
walked by on the other side and not
invested in good quality jobs since the
end of the coal industry but you also
need a government is going to invest in
the future to reduce those inequalities
it's a Labour government that will
invest in the future and we need to
maintain a trading relationship with
Europe a trading relationship for our
manufacturing industry and for our food
processing and food industries as well
also issues like medicine supply and of
course the Northern Ireland border is a
key issue and any deal that damages the
Belfast agreement which is an
international treaty is simply not going
to work ok I just want bring you back to
my question mm-hmm does labor now back a
second referendum and all circumstances
what would say is there'll be a second
referendum to make a choice between
whatever deal is arranged and what the
public want including a labor deal if
you are in power well if we're in power
yes of course the same thing would apply
because I want to make sure that we get
to the end of this process where we have
a fixed position in this country I have
spent the last two years trying to
ensure that we put forward the labor
view which was a customs union with the
European Union trade access and
protection of rights that was the one
that got the best vote in Parliament but
didn't gain
Theresa Mays proposals were roundly
defeated on three occasions so if you do
want to see a second referendum in all
circumstances how are you going to
campaign tonight your Manny's been
campaigning you a lot all your life you
can be campaigning for leave or you can
be campaigning for remain all we serve
is in the event of the No Deal breaks it
will campaign to remain but what if
Labour negotiates attack well we we've
got to get into office first to
negotiate a deal you see was it a
winning election first we're in election
then we'll reopen those talks of the
European Union but at the moment the
crew the danger is a No Deal exit on the
31st of October with all the problems of
that brings I understand that you're a
postive No Deal but when my head starts
to hurt slightly as I'm still struggling
to see exactly what is in jeremy
corbyn's heart when it comes to brexit
i'm it's crystal clear what Boris
Johnson wants like it or not it's
crystal clear what Joseph Winston wants
what does Jeremy Corbyn want do you want
to stay in the EU or jointly investment
jobs trade and equality both in or out
of the EU I want those things but I go
back to the point
we're different through in or out
doesn't it you can't do say you want to
investment and opportunity in or out
mean what we give most is it was
actually a very credible deal bespoke
customs union with the EU and the trade
arrangements you would have achieved
those things it didn't go through
Parliament that's the problem
so that's your preference though rather
that was what we put forward and that
obviously is why I put it forward except
my issue is also uniting people in the
country my party is the only one that
has significant numbers of people who
voted both remain and leave in the
referendum my party represents people
all over the country we want to bring
people together which is why I spend a
lot of time listening to an awful lot of
divergent views over this whole issue
and then we came up with the proposal
that I put to our National Executive our
party which is what we have you say you
talk about listening you talk about
trying to unite people but isn't it also
the time for leadership people want to
know what you stand for leadership comes
from listening when you listen to people
and then you take people forward with
you we are then dictate we hear a lot
about what other people feel
Tom Watson John McDonald and the classy
speculation about people in your office
but this is one saying the leadership
question is crucial isn't it if you
stand up and say
this is what we believe this is what
we're going to do I've certainly well of
course your referendum and will be a
decision made of people of this country
okay and now we need to talk about
anti-semitism and this is your first
major interview since the panorama
documentary I don't if you've watched it
mm-hmm and what did you think that I was
upset at the feelings of some of our
former staff what they said I was upset
at the way the program was characterized
and presented and we have put in some
complaints surrounding that I'm very
clear there is no place whatsoever for
anti-semitism in our society in our
communities or in my party since I
became leader I asked and she did it
Shami Chakrabarti she'll report into it
and develop a process when Jenny Formby
took over as general secretary and
successor to him McNichol I asked her to
deal with it in a speedy and timely
manner we recruited more staff and we
improved our processes the process who
have gone through four times faster I
also recognize that where there is prima
facie evidence of serious abuse then
there is a need for a faster process I
looked into that and put it to the
Shadow Cabinet at the parliamentary
Labour Party and the National Executive
of my own party last week and they
agreed with me there had to be a faster
process which is now being developed
into rules which go before this year's
conference we are very clear we're not
accepting any form of anti-semitism in
our party we've also by the way adopted
a definition of Islamophobia and any
other form of racism is totally
unacceptable were completely open about
that and where it happens and it has
happened in cases of less than North
when one cent of our membership we deal
with it and just to look at some of the
allegations that former members of the
Labour Party made in that documentary
and they were talking about effectively
interference in the process and I'm just
gonna read some of what they said and
cap bokkeum I quit the party with
nowhere to go and had a breakdown Sam
Matthews I actively considered
committing suicide Louise Withers Green
I was signed off with depression and
anxiety I mean how do you feel when you
hear that I feel very sorry and very sad
for them the first thing I did when I
became leader of the party was to ask a
senior staff what processes that were
available for staff support because of
stress at work that was without anything
to do with anti-semitism just the whole
principles of stress at work I feel very
strongly about that and that support has
to be there some of those people had to
work very hard they were overwhelmed by
cases letters and so on and remember our
party membership virtually undermines
virtually troubled well they were being
asked to work very fast on a lot of very
complex issues and in some cases they
had to sift through a lot of things to
find it actually the complainant
sometimes we weren't even labour party
members can you guarantee you that since
Jenny Formby became general secretary
there's been no interference by you or
anyone in your office on any all we've
said is get the cases done as quickly as
you can in a timely fair and legally
sustainable manner
okay and now well I don't understand
when I look at the under semitism story
we've talked about before you spoken
about in interviews before it's been
going on for years now why don't you
just set up an independent process to
deal with it now we then just stop all
of this wouldn't it no that's what
people have report for that's what you
know for example the Board of Deputies
and Jewish Leadership Council court for
why don't you just do it nobody else has
an independent process when their own
organizations what we do have is legal
oversight of the process to ensure
consistency in decision-making and when
and the Equality Human Rights Commission
concludes its
report we will obviously listen very
carefully to what they have to say I do
think there has to be a legally robust
process we also have a degree of
independence in the party with something
called the national constitutional
committee which is completely
independent
in the national executive they make the
final decision do you take
responsibility I'm the leader of the
party therefore I must take
responsibility for it happens in our
party and I'm absolutely determined our
place has to be say safe and welcoming
our party's safe and welcoming to people
of all faiths all religions and all
groups do you think someone allowed to
have a blind spot under certain people
in politics do sometimes across the line
and confuse issues and can dip into
anti-semitic tropes and language that's
why I've introduced an education program
with a substantial pack of education
materials which has been sent out last
week so that we say to people just be
careful on your use of language it is
not acceptable look at the history of
the growth of racism in this this
continent over the last century and look
now at the rise of the far-right
in Central Europe and indeed in Western
Europe and of course in the United
States as well ok and now we're talking
at the end of a very busy week what we
saw among other things was more MPs
appointed to cabinet from ethnic
minorities than we've ever seen before I
mean admittedly it's a pretty low bar is
that something you're welcome
well I welcome diversity of course and I
welcome that our Parliament is beginning
to look a bit more like the rest of the
population does but it's got a long way
to go after all as 1987 the first four
black MPs were elected and it was quite
a while before substantially more joined
them
our Shadow Cabinet is extremely diverse
our team is extremely diverse our party
membership is extremely diverse our
society is very diverse but you've got
to start doing monitoring of all big
organizations where you find diversity
often at the lowest levels in any
organization and that sort of diversity
reduces and diminishes the nearer you
get to the top of it but it's also about
education it's about understanding it's
about history so I'm very proud that
dawn Butler our shadow equalities
minister has produced the ideas and the
emancipation education trust so we can
understand something our children can
understand
something more about how the slave trade
came about how the slave trade was
opposed and how eventually slavery was
abolished I just want to read you a
tweet that was sent by a shadow minister
Clive Lewis towards James Cleverley
who's the new party chairman of the
Conservative Party and he congratulates
a table on the appointment and said I'm
just sorry that you and other black
members of the cabinet how to sell your
souls and self-respect to get there do
you think they sold us honest they're
conservatives they believe in
conservatism they've been appointed in
their party I'd leave it at that
I want diversity at all levels in our
society and he also was talking about
things that he thinks that Boris Johnson
has said that are racist
do you think Boris Johnson's racist
Boris Johnson has said some awful
comments about black children about
Muslim women and about people within our
society in our community which I
absolutely condemn I hope he will
understand the hurt that he caused of
the remarks that he made while we're
talking about diversity and we had a
first female Liberal Democrat leader
appointed this week as well
Labor's not the only party that hasn't
had a woman leader is that something you
should be ashamed of I'm not ashamed of
it but there will be a woman leader in
the future of that I'm very sure what
you like the next needed to be a woman
listen one thing I've said is I ain't
going to get involved in choosing that
okay because I'm very happy in the job
I'm doing in a very determined to win
the general election so we get a Labour
government but that Labour government
will be gender balance there will be an
equality or a majority in the cabinet of
women and will be a very diverse cabinet
around that table because we represent
all parts and all communities of this
country and if that election isn't until
2022 we still fight it I'm fine I'm fit
I'm ready I'm raring to go
Jeremy Corbyn thank you very much thank
you very much